- Hey everyone, thank you so much
for joining us this afternoon.
I'm Philip from Baseten,
and I'm going to be talking
about high performance inference
for Frontier AI models.
Really quickly, we're
gonna cover a few things.
We're gonna cover the idea
of inference engineering,
the rise of open source foundation models,
the components of an inference stack,
including runtime
performance optimization,
and infrastructure.
And then look at what
that does in production.
So I'm from Baseten.
We like to say Baseten is inference.
We are an inference provider.
We're in the AWS marketplace
and we serve open source,
fine tuned and custom
models on infrastructure
that's purpose built for production.
We think about inference
in a few different parts.
Number one is performance.
At the runtime level,
you want to make sure
that your actual GPU is
utilized to its fullest extent
to create the highest possible throughput
at the lowest possible latency.
On the infrastructure level
once you have that incredibly
efficient model service,
eventually you're gonna
have enough traffic
that you are going to be saturating it.
So you need to be able
to scale horizontally
to two replicas, 10 replicas, a hundred,
a thousand replicas, across
clusters and across regions.
And then all of that needs to be wrapped
in a delightful developer experience
and delivered with hands-on support
from expert forward deployed engineers.
So why did we build this?
Why does all of this exist?
It really starts with open
source frontier AI models,
and today there are well over
2 million open source models
on Hugging Face.
This is up from just a
few tens of thousands,
four or five years ago.
And with these models,
it's not just about the
number, it's about the quality.
Open source models are
now routinely hitting
frontier quality across
different parameter sizes.
When you look at stuff like
the Kimi K2 Thinking model,
or think back to January Deep Seek R1,
we see open source models
finally crossing the gap
versus closed models and
delivering frontier intelligence.
But it's not just for LLMs
though, doing this in voice.
We have outstanding models for
automatic speech recognition
for text-to-speech
generation for diarization,
we have great image generation models
from FLUX and Stable Diffusion.
We have models for generating
and processing videos,
as well as embedding models
that can be used for all kinds
of tasks on various data,
including both text data
and multimodal data.
So with all of these different models,
all at frontier Quality,
you need something
that we call inference engineering.
So inference engineering is the process
of running AI models in production,
and there are three
principles that kind of define
this engineering practice.
The first is the idea
that optimization requires constraints.
So if we're going to optimize
our systems performance,
we need a goal that
we're optimizing toward.
We can't just try and make
it better at everything.
The second is that scale unlocks
more performance techniques.
If we're going to use something like
large scale parallelism, disaggregation,
or other performance techniques,
we're going to need enough traffic
that we can cost effectively
leverage the hardware required
to actually pull this off.
And finally, we're going
to need to stay dynamic.
We're going to not configure our system
runtime statically and deploy it.
We want our system to be able
to update itself in real time
to adjust to the different
traffic configuration
that's coming in from our live user base.
And one thing I like to talk about
to sort of illustrate these
points is the idea of, you know,
I'm a big fan of the NFL,
and one of the reasons that
I like watching the NFL
is you see those guys
out there on the field
and they're big, they're
fast, they're strong,
and they're playing the sport,
but they're not as big as Sumo wrestlers,
they're not as fast as Olympic sprinters,
they're not as strong as a
say champion power lifter.
And I think this is a useful lesson
when it comes to inference optimization.
Sometimes it's easy to get
caught up in just trying
to be number one on whatever benchmark.
What really matters is making sure
that you have the right
mix of capabilities
to actually serve the unique
needs of your application.
And a great example of
someone who's really found
that balance is OpenEvidence.
So the easiest way for me
to explain OpenEvidence
is it's a chat application
for doctors to be able to
get up to date information.
And so there were massively
successful AI healthcare startup
and the CTOs said about Baseten
that we support billions
of custom and fine-tuned
LLM calls per week
for serving high stakes
medical information
to healthcare providers
at just about every
major healthcare facility in the country.
So how do you achieve this scale?
How do you do that with
this excellent performance
and reliably enough to be
used in a healthcare setting?
So that really comes down to
the idea of an inference stack.
Again, inference is multiple parts.
You need both the runtime
component, you need to make sure
that your individual GPU is
working as well as possible.
And you need the infrastructure component.
You need to make sure that you can scale
that optimized instance
across many, many replicas.
So let's start with the runtime layer.
What does that look like?
So inference runtime is
really about applied research.
There's all of these
really interesting papers
that are constantly getting published.
You know, NeurIPS is
in San Diego right now.
There's a lot of really great
research happening there.
And the question is, how do you
take these ideas from papers
and actually apply them in production?
So one of the major pieces
of optimization technology
that we use often is quantization.
Quantization is the idea
of moving from say like a 16-bit
floating point number
format down to eight bits
or four bits so that you
can access higher power
tensor cores as well as access
or take better advantage
of your memory bandwidth
by sending less data with
each pass through the model.
So we think about
quantization both in terms
of being really selective
with the formats we're using.
I just gave a talk at Nvidia's
booth yesterday over there
about everything we're doing with NVF P4,
which is a new micro scaling
data format with Blackwell.
And then we also think carefully
about what we quantize.
Quantization isn't as simple
as taking your entire model,
chucking it in your model optimizer
and bringing out a quantized model.
You want to think
carefully about quantizing,
maybe just weights, just
weights and activations.
Maybe you can carefully
quantize the KV cache to FP8.
You probably wanna leave attention alone.
And even within these neural networks,
within each of these components,
maybe you quantize only the middle layers
and leave the input and
output layers intact.
So there's a lot of granularity
that you can do in
quantization to make sure
that you preserve quality.
Another main driver for us of
performance is speculation.
Speculative decoding.
You can use these different algorithms
to generate draft tokens,
which increases tokens per
second on memory bound decode.
With every pass through the model,
we can create more than one token,
which is really promising.
With speculation we do a
lot of different algorithms.
Some of the ones that are
seeing really great results
right now are EAGLE-3 which
uses a sort of specialized
trained model to do the speculation.
The model takes hidden
states from the target model
and generates draft tokens.
We also do a lot of look ahead
decoding, engram speculation,
especially in the code completion field
where you have a very
constrained vocabulary.
Another really important
optimization for us is caching.
We do a lot of KV cache aware routing
to ensure high hit
weights on KV cache reuse.
And with KV cache aware routing,
this is especially important
for stuff like code completion.
So a customer of ours,
Zed, which is a IDE,
was able to with the
Baseten inference stack,
including a good deal of KV cache reuse,
achieve 2x faster
end-to-end code completion.
So as you're typing, those
suggestions pop up twice as fast
with a 45% lower P90 latency
and 3.5x faster or
higher system throughput.
So that's just one example of
what these techniques can achieve.
A couple other things we think
about a lot are parallelism,
especially with the rise
of mixture of experts
as the predominant architecture
within large scale language models.
You have techniques like
tensor and export parallelism
that need to be carefully balanced
to ensure that you're
making the right trade-offs
between latency and throughput
and also with other modalities
like video generation,
which challenge even
eight 8XB 200 systems.
You need approaches
like context parallelism
to ensure that you are
able to split attention
across these eight GPUs
and use all of your compute efficiently.
And finally, one more runtime optimization
I'm really excited about is disaggregation
where you separate prefill and
decode onto separate workers
that scale independently.
This allows you to do
a lot of these things
I just talked about as
well as adopting different,
you know, kernel strategies,
different run times and
specialize each of your workers
for the specific challenge of
either compute bound prefill
or memory bandwidth bound decode.
So disaggregation, another thing supported
by Dynamo by the way, is another one
of these model performance techniques
that we've found a lot of interest in.
But again, all of that together,
I just went through five of the primary
model performance techniques.
Even if you do a world class
job of implementing those,
that's not going to be enough
for your production inference service.
You also need the
infrastructure to match that.
And a big part of the
infrastructure component
is the idea of autoscaling.
So a lot of companies, especially
companies that start out
with large training clusters,
end up with sort of fixed
amounts of GPU capacity.
The problem with fixed
GPU capacity for inference
is that traffic fluctuates
maybe for business applications.
It's highest during business
hours, lower overnight,
lower on the weekends.
And when you have fluctuating
traffic, you know,
maybe you are a consumer application
and sometimes you go viral on TikTok
and get a million users overnight,
some days it's a lot quieter.
In these cases, your static capacity
is not going to be a great
match for your traffic.
When traffic is low, you're
gonna have wasted spend.
And when traffic is high,
even with all of these optimizations,
your system won't have enough throughput,
you'll start missing SLAs.
So that's where autoscaling comes in
to closely match the GPU capacity
that you're provisioning at
any given time to your traffic.
At Baseten, we do a lot of traffic based
autoscaling decisions
and we're able to get this
capacity via something
that we call multi-cluster
capacity management.
While many inference services
rely on only capacity
within a single region,
so let's say you are only in US-East-1,
you build your entire
inference system there.
With multi-cluster capacity management,
you are able to pool compute
across multiple regions,
across multiple independent clusters.
And with a single global control plane,
treat it as a unified
resource where you're able to,
if you have say 10 replicas,
schedule I don't know, eight
of them on one instance,
two on the other, that gets you, you know,
great things like active
active reliability
across regions and makes
sure that you have access
to both more capacity, more resilience,
as well as more geographic
proximity to your end users
for globally distributed applications.
And that matters because no matter
how fast you make your model server,
no matter how fast this bid is
where the actual inference
workload is running.
If your network latency is slow
because you're sending a
request from, I don't know,
Singapore to California and back,
or if your queue depth is high
because you are waiting on, you
know, you only have 10 GPUs,
but you have 20 GPUs worth of traffic,
no matter how fast this model service is
from that inference runtime
layer we talked about earlier,
your end-to-end inference
time is going to suffer.
So that's why it matters
to do both the runtime
and the infrastructure
optimizations together
to ensure great end-to-end latency.
And a another sort of customer
who's experienced this
is a company called Latent.
Latent is a pharmaceutical search company
and they like to talk
about how we save them
a lot of stress and developer time
in implementing highly reliable inference
with this multi-cluster strategy
and with these autoscaling capabilities
within the inference
optimized infrastructure.
But everything I've talked about so far
has been mostly focused on the idea
of large language models.
And I feel like large language models
and AI deservedly somewhat synonymous,
but there's a lot of other modalities
of open source models
like we were talking about
at the beginning.
There's image generation
models, video generation
and vetting models,
text-to-speech, speech-to-text,
and all sorts of novel
modalities being developed today.
So a great example of
adapting this specific setup
to a given modality is the
idea of embedding inference.
So embedding models take text as input
and output vectors that encode
the semantic meaning of that text.
And I should say also though,
multimodal embedding models
that take images of videos
and encode those similarly.
So if you have this great capability
around running language models,
well how do you then turn
around and run embedding models?
It turns out that embedding models
like many other modalities
are architecturally very, very similar
to large language models.
Most of the frontier quality
embedding models today
are stuff like EmbeddingGemma, Qwen Embed.
These models that are
built out of open source
large language models.
As such, you can use the
same runtime at the end here
if you're able to build the
rest of the system around it.
Sort of a common theme in
what I've been talking about
with inference today.
So for example, for based
on embedding inference,
you would have a model
server sitting in front of it
to process the requests.
A multi-worker tokenizer
that's able to take the
generally hundreds of thousands
of individual sentences
or individual inputs
that might be batched together
in a single inference request
to a embedding model in particular,
stick it into a batch manager,
queue it up and have a,
you know, take advantage
of the same sort of token
by token inflight batching,
continuous batching mechanism
that your runtime provides
for language models and
then all of a sudden
you have the same high
quality inference service
in a completely novel modality.
So we've done this for embeddings,
we've done this for
speech-to-text, for text-to-speech
for image generation,
for video generation.
So all six major modalities of model
that you could think of.
And a customer of ours who's
using this is Superhuman.
You might know them as
they were recently acquired
by Grammarly who then themselves
rebranded as superhuman.
So Loic, he was the CTO
of the original Superhuman email app.
With this Baseten embedding inference,
they were able to cut
the P95 latency by 80%
across tons of different
fine tune embedding models
that power key features in their app.
And you'll notice one
thing I like to highlight,
I'm always proudest to
highlight these P90, these P95,
P99 latency gains
because they show the impact
of this two part problem
that I've been talking
about all day up here,
which is, you know, it's not
enough to be able to run fast.
You need to be able to run fast reliably.
And that comes not only from the runtime
but also from the infrastructure.
So to review, if you're going to build
inference in production, you
need to build four things.
You need to deliver
world class performance,
state-of-the-art performance
in terms of time to first
token, tokens per second
or whatever other metrics matter
to you and your end users.
You need to pair that with infrastructure
that delivers four nines
of better with reliability
so that you can trust your applications
for mission critical deployments
in fields like healthcare.
You need to be able to scale
GPU capacity across regions
and you know, maybe even
across different VPCs
so that you can handle,
you know, AI powered
applications are growing fast.
We see customers routinely
growing by multiples
and multiples compounding
within a single year.
And so you need to be able
to very rapidly both
scale on a month to month
sort of global view.
You need to be able to scale compute
as well as individually
within any given day.
You need to be able to scale automatically
up and down with traffic.
And then finally, you need
to be able to do that,
not just once, not just for one model,
not just for one modality,
but for any model.
Any of the 2 million open
source models on Hugging Face,
any fine tuned model, any customized model
that enterprises are
increasingly turning to
to deliver differentiated
value in production.
All four of those things
need to be done together.
Thank you for the time today.
I really enjoyed speaking with you.
So we're going to be at booth 1632,
which is like right over that
way behind the reddest booth.
We've got these artificially
intelligent T-shirts,
we've got a bunch of my
teammates over there doing demos.
If you have any questions
whatsoever about the content
that we talked about today,
please join me over there.
Thank you so much for your time.